We tend to reproach ourselves for staring out of the window.
You're supposed to be working or studying or ticking off things on your to-do list.
It can seem almost the definition of wasted time.
It appears to produce nothing, to serve no purpose!
There is not prestige in it.
We don't go around and say: "I had a great day, the high point was staring out of the window"
But maybe, in a better society, that's just the sort of thing people would say to one another.
The point of staring out of the window is - paradoxically - not to find out, what's going on outside.
It is rather an exercise in discovering the contents of our own minds.
It's easy to imagine we know what we think, what we feel and what's going on in our heads.
But we rarely do entirely.
There is huge amount of what makes us who we are, that circulates, unexplored and unused.
It's shy and doesn't emerge under the pressure of direct questioning.
If we do it right, staring out of the window offers us a way to listen out
for the quieter suggestions and perspectives of our inner natures.
The philosopher Plato suggested a metaphor for the mind.
It's full of ideas, like a birds fluttering around in the aviary of our brains.
But, in order for the birds to settle, Plato understood that we need periods of calm.
Staring out of the window offers such an opportunity.
The potential of daydreaming isn't recognized by societies obsessed with productivity.
But some of our greatest insights come when we stop trying to be purposeful
and instead respect to the creative potential of reverie.
Window daydreaming is a strategic rebellion against the excessive demands
of the immediate -but ultimately insignificant- pressures,
in favor of the diffuse, but very serious search for the insights of our deeper selves.